welcome to this video playing the Dark
Passenger does he have a name no yeah I
think I looked at this for Tony times I
should really do something else I'm Chad
not always this Bogle anyway Queen takes
is the way to do it and then the Knight
to c3 night takes is pretty passive I
mean not bad but a bit passive okay
and the night is not influencing the
center much I can easily go like 65 and
okay Ike once so maybe go 92 93
something like that no that's possible
it's not a not a bad setup now it
doesn't look very dangerous but it's
playable
okay the night on g6 looks a bit strange
because there's a pawn on g3 but my idea
is to push the edge pawn and try to get
some counter play down that's
interesting I can just do this right as
nothing wrong with that I Scott night c4
hmm I didn't really appreciate that i
was thinking i can can just place it 60
somewhere okay yet nights you form
probably then that takes on d4 wasn't
such a brilliant idea so terrible that
really not not very much necessary okay
so what now do I want to try this age 5
business here z4 lined up so i probably
should coordinate a little bit better
before I think about fancy H porn pushes
okay taking why is it raining so much
okay we'll see queen here for mochi aid
maybe head but should be six there's
look the one is unprotected but i know i
go to you six I think why not come on
let's play it not waste time for Bishop
d5 and the pawn so so just be sure t5
hmm that's interesting so he goes into
we should be three is that any good now
the double porn probably doesn't help me
so I'm taking
need the king I think it's it's pretty
equal this position don't don't see
white having much okay okay okay okay he
might be able to get get this night to
the 6 mm mm mm that's true maybe Ponting
so is that too panicky
it's not so bad i have 98 and tonight's
just six stuff
thief no king is six is going to play
rookie 154 king of three key I will see
I can go to the five right so let's do
this this is really hardly any end game
that you can play without having your
king activated so if it gives me that
opportunity check I'm going to take it
yeah even though he can do this but he
is no he has no one entry squared the
mood
hmm ok I'm playing the sir Knight b6
mate mate
oh it was very helpful very naive g5
gym time morning yeah I know but what
can you do here is rookie five no set
made rookie five it is almost made
amazing man if I get in route g8 Candice
bloody made and now it's gone weekly
five amazing check
j what a game I was I was really
thinking I'm just playing for the wind
there with a key 125 but yet the meat
this meeting idea I was really
remarkable anyway check I'm still kind
of hanging on there I mean it's lost but
what can you do you threatened made
again
okay black resigned now I didn't see
that coming at all so with this that
that is totally totally changing the
whole evaluation check that mating ideas
is turning everything around I mean not
around I mean then then why does better
it's just I didn't see that that I'm in
a meeting net here and I cannot really
do much about it I was thinking my king
is active Mia he cannot play a four and
i'm going for four stuff here and going
to enter or something I there isn't it's
just made it just check made the engine
suggests this the point is if he tries
the same thing now I can go rookie seven
but they are even here without the rooks
again goes here that was very nice yeah
that that makes this whole thing that
then everything is wrong I have to do
have to play differently then and I
don't believe that I'm much worse e
which is agreed with the engine agrees
upon it gives zero point form now what
does not have many ways to make any
progress engine wants to play 94 and
this is very dry that ya head rook
endgame is very Jewish kinky sex and
like he had a 5 and so on that that will
be drawn yeah I also wasn't vicious I
know every didn't didn't think about
that there might be check was thinking
okay I'm activating the king and so on
and then what a cold shower and 92 it's
immediately lost wow that was very nice
okay thanks for watching